resident evil village is here and it's
freaking awesome that's not the point of
this video but
i just want you to know that it is
incredible and you should check out our
review
but more importantly this video right
here is to tell you that if you're a
resident evil veteran excited to play
village
you should consider playing the game on
hardcore difficulty for your first time
as somebody who plays way too much
resident evil and knows all the series
tricks
one of the few issues i had with
resident evil village was that i thought
it was a
bit too easy on standard mode and it's
easy to feel a little
too comfortable while playing for me the
ideal resident evil experience is one
where you are
constantly riding the line of having
just barely enough ammo and health to
survive
learning to play smarter on a higher
difficulty rewards you with some extra
breathing room
but it just takes a few bad mistakes for
resources to dwindle and
put you into some serious danger this to
me
is the secret sauce of resident evil's
survival horror
and my favorite games in the franchise
nail that dynamic
my first time playing village on
standard however i rarely found myself
in this sweet spot of tension
ammo was never really a problem and as a
result i
barely touched the game's crafting
system simply because
i never needed to it wasn't until the
final fourth of the game that things
ramped up and
ammo scarcity and health became more
serious
as a result i only died a handful of
times
most of which were a factor of the
game's environment or
timing based challenges not combat the
game has all of the
pieces in place to make a harrowing
survival experience
work but the balance just isn't quite
right
and i don't think that standard demanded
i take full advantage of its mechanics
as much as i would like
this isn't necessarily an indictment of
the standard mode
it's not bad by any means it's simply
that as a veteran of the resident evil
series i am bringing with me all of my
knowledge of how these games
work and take advantage of that nailing
headshots avoiding enemies you don't
need a kill
scavenging every possible nook and
cranny for items and money
this game absolutely rewards this kind
of play
on standard you'll often find yourself
feeling a bit too
powerful and prepared than what the
setting might suggest
this of course has its own benefits not
worrying as much about ammo for easy to
focus more on the act of combat itself
which gets really fun when the hordes of
lichen start to flood in
so before i go any further i should say
that it is
one thousand percent okay to play the
game on standard if that's what you
enjoy
i personally like that terrifying
feeling of having your back against the
wall
that's why i love the series but some
people just want something a little more
relaxed and that's okay
you also might be the kind of player
whose skill level is more attuned for
standard
and will find it to be the right level
of challenge so don't let anyone tell
you you're lesser for it
difficulties exist for a reason and
people play games differently
all of that said if you crave that
resource management
the stress of not having enough first
aid and love it when one wrong move can
turn a good run
into sheer tension then i'm gonna
recommend you play your first time on
hardcore
after finishing the game i loaded up a
fresh save on hardcore to see if it
scratched that
itch and i was not disappointed
it only takes a swing or two to go from
full health to into the red
leaving a lot less room for air when it
comes to getting hit
playing it safe learning the right time
to dodge and running a hallway
back to give yourself distance becomes
mandatory
even with weaker foes it's not that it's
hard
is that it asks you to put your all into
each and every fight
and always be alert something that i
never quite felt on standard
since damage from enemy hits were more
lacks
i also found myself engaging with the
block more often
something i rarely touched on standard
because i
never felt in enough danger that i
needed to rely on it
it's in hardcore that you realize how
important blocking really is
the damage reduced when blocking is a
lot more significant than you might
think
probably because you wouldn't think
blocking an axe swing with your hands
would be
all that effective but seriously the
difference between taking a hit and
blocking
is huge you're so vulnerable and
hardcore that you need to use it
all the time particularly in close
encounter fights where it becomes
basically mandatory blocking also
opens up a counter move where you can
push enemies away
and sometimes even disarm them of their
weapon a key strategy you'll want to
take advantage of
and another thing that i never touched
on standard
finally there is ammo and crafting the
amount of ammo and crafting materials
gained remains the same as standard
but with enemies taking more bullets to
dispatch the balance feels much more
aligned with what i was looking for
you always have just barely enough ammo
to make it through an encounter
sometimes with only a few bullets
remaining and the sudden stress of
needing to find more before the next
thing jumps at you from around a corner
yet it doesn't swing in the other
direction of being unfair
there was only one moment where i
completely ran out of ammo
and it's because i was being careless
and wasting them on enemies in an
optional area i was backtracking to and
probably should have just dodged around
them
a decision i never even contemplated on
standard but
often considered wall on hardcore on
hardcore you truly appreciate how well
done
item placement and resource balance is
and when it's not
bullets it's crafting materials which
you guessed it
i actually needed to use this time
having to make the tough choice to craft
a few more shotgun shells but lose
material needed for a first
aid is something that added a strategic
layer to the hardcore experience
despite only taking a break for a few
days between playthroughs
hardcore felt very fresh the game
demanded that i engage with all of its
systems and played smart
it took what i already thought was a
pretty fantastic survival horror
experience
and elevated it to one of the best
survival horror experiences i've ever
had
okay have i convinced you that hardcore
is pretty cool awesome
well i'm thrilled but i should warn you
about one thing
in a loving homage to resident evil 4
the first major combat encounter is a
harrowing survival where you are swamped
by
way too many enemies to shock your
system before things
slow back down and settle into a more
natural rhythm
it's a great set piece on standard but
it's kind of frustrating on hardcore
despite already beating the game i died
multiple times during this moment
the coolness of it slowly washing away
leaving only frustration
as i kept getting hit in the back by
that one guy jesus
stop doing that
it's a rough sequence especially if
you're still learning how the game is
played
maybe you'll be fine with it but i
wanted to bring it up as it was the
one sour note in my hardcore experience
the good thing is that once the moment
has
passed the game's pacing and combat
settles
and it's just excellent from then on so
if you can get past the opening
encounter
you're golden so there you go if
everything i just talked about
sounds like something you're interested
in hardcore might be for you
and i would really recommend taking a
risk and giving it a shot however i do
want to reiterate but i don't think
standard mode is the wrong way to
experience this game
it's more that it won't demand full use
of village's gameplay systems
and that in itself comes with the
benefit of having a smoother playthrough
meanwhile hardcore demands you learn and
master the game
weigh the cost and benefit of crafting
scavenge everything
and make every bullet count if a bit of
a uphill struggle is the kind of
experience you're looking for
out of a resident evil game you can't go
wrong with hardcore
thank you all so much for watching this
video i hope you all have a fantastic
time with resident evil village
if you're watching this video and
interested in hardcore you're probably
already a pretty big resident
veteran but maybe you need a little bit
of a refresher in which case we have
some great survival tips from
kurt that you should go check out
[Applause]
you